in tonight's whatever happened to
segment president Trump's military
parade here in Washington it is shaping
up to be something a little different
than originally planned national
security correspondent Jennifer Griffin
tells us where things stand right now
the date is set Saturday November 10th
one day before Veterans Day but the
military parade in Washington may not be
what President Trump had in mind when he
watched French fighter jets and tanks
parading down the champs-elysees in
Paris last summer sparking his idea to
honor America's veterans language in the
Defense Authorization Act passed in
Congress this week prohibits forces from
taking part that may be needed for war
quote to ensure that veterans and those
currently serving remained the parade's
focus and that efforts to restore
readiness are not slowed the NDAA
prohibits the use of operational units
or equipment in the parade if the
Secretary of Defense believes such use
will hamper readiness the money will
come from the military's operations and
maintenance budget according to the
Republican chairman of the House Armed
Services Committee it says if any
operational units are used and secretary
mattis has to certify that it will not
affect readiness the Pentagon's top
officer has assigned us Northern Command
based in Colorado tasked with protecting
the homeland to pull it off initial
guidance in March called for quote
honoring the history of the US military
starting from the Revolutionary War and
the war of 1812 to today and coincide
with the 100th anniversary of the end of
World War one it's not clear now how
much the parade will cost taxpayers I've
seen various different cost estimates
from between I think 10 million and 30
million depending on the size of the
parade
almost exactly the same amount that
those war games president Trump's craft
with South Korea saying doing so would
save the taxpayer a lot of money
the bill tries to make sure this parade
is focused on the men and women who have
served and and really tailor it towards
the hundredth anniversary of the end of
World War one but also give an
opportunity to honor those veterans
who've never had a parade like those who
fought in Vietnam those who have fought
in Iraq and Afghanistan more recently
the DC City Council was concerned roads
would be damaged with heavy armaments
rolling down Pennsylvania Avenue a
spokesman for the u.s. Northern Command
said at this time we do not intend to
use tanks in the parade Chris Jennifer
thank you